MIDNIGHT SWEETS
This program is intended
for sweets lovers.
Your sweet moments, Midnight Sweets.
It's started.
It's a TV program
that introduces delicious sweets.
I always look forward to it enough to wait
like this for 30 minutes before it starts.
There has been a flood of complaints
about airing a sweets show at midnight,
but I have a fast metabolism,
so I have no issue with it.
I wonder what tonight's sweets are.
Our guest for tonight
is an actor, Tooru Mugami.
Good evening.
Okay, let's bet for the second race.
Winner gets this whole piece of cake.
Sure. I'm fueled with sugar.
I will let you choose first.
Okay, then...
I got it. Number five, Big Boobs.
Does the owner even love the horse?
Have you picked one?
I will. Second sight using telepathy,
here I go!
Come on, number four!
It's best to gather information
from the most involved parties.
-I should go easy with my twisted leg.
-So sleepy...
-I want to be free-range.
-My leg twisted?
I twisted my leg!
I twisted my leg due to weight gain?
I've twisted my front leg.
Too many twisted legs.
I’m on a roll!
That's him! Big Boobs!
No! I can't pick you!
Any other good horses?
It's number nine!
Number nine will win the race!
Big Boobs is fast!
Big Boobs finished in first place!
Yum.
Finish it and leave.
Did you see the new teacher?
-He's gonna be our homeroom teacher!
-For real?
He looks like a criminal.
His face gets dissed a lot.
I'm not sure about his face,
but he seems nice.
-He looks guilty of sexual assaults.
-He sure does.
You, too.
That's enough! You can't judge people
by appearances.
Hairo!
You guys are just overreacting
and being so rude to him.
Kuboyasu!
-Right, we're rude to the pervert teacher.
-That pervert doesn't have to be that.
How rude.
That's already enough.
He should be here in no time.
Here it is. I'm so nervous.
Maybe I'm breathing hard
and my face is blushing.
Here he is!
I shouldn't let them notice
my nervousness.
I have to stay calm, walk in slowly...
and smile!
-He is a pervert!
-He is.
What? They're so quiet.
Is something wrong?
No! Stop it, animal!
"Animal"?
It's an antonym for teacher.
Is she nervous? How can I make her relax?
I know.
Don't be so nervous, Yumehara.
How did you know my name?
Because you're my student.
I spent a week memorizing their names.
Now I know all 11th graders' names.
Did he research me?
That's not quite right.
Not only your name, but your address, too.
Better stop right there.
No! I'm going to transfer schools!
Satou is Mr. Standard. He never falls
under the average. He is a majority guy.
MIDDLE CLASS - ORTHODOX
THE WORLD STANDARD
On the other hand,
Takahashi is just a mook.
He never exceeds the average.
He is a boring cliche.
TYPICAL FAMILY BACKGROUND
THE MASSES - LAYMAN
Now you know. Don't ever say that again.
You just used different words
for the same thing.
Look at his seat.
He's right in the middle of the class.
-Wait. It's not in the middle, is it?
-What? It can't be. Did they switch seats?
Isn't that Hii sitting next to him?
-She's not normal!
Why is the super unlucky girl
sitting next to Satou?
-Is it that outrageous?
-Of course.
Not having the middle seat is
already wrong.
His normalness never misses
the middle seat even if it's a drawing.
You sure he's not a psychic?
This is gonna be a problem.
-Hii's bad luck involves others.
-That's right.
But, since Satou is an average guy,
his luck is also average.
His life is boring. Nothing really bad
or good has ever happened to him.
Are you dissing him?
It's the fight of the century.
Unlucky vs. Normal!
UNLUCKY - NORMAL
Oh, I don't care...
Here it is! A girl carrying a fish tank.
When she drops it,
will Satou be affected by it?
She can't avoid dropping it?
Here she comes!
Oh...
Now what?
LUCK METER
He's got wet normally!
And he is reacting normally, too!
Did he lose?
Even Satou becomes an unlucky guy
when Hii is with him?
I'm sorry! You got wet because of me!
Don't worry, it's nothing.
And it wasn't your fault...
LUCK METER
Oh, I'm sorry...
His meter went back to 50%!
Right, his good luck of seeing her bra
offset his bad luck.
-And his reaction is normal!
-Hey...
-Shall we get back to the class...
-This is not the time for that.
Her bad luck didn't work on him!
I get it! Because Hii Suzumiya transferred
into this class,
the whole class has been unfortunate.
But it didn't affect Satou, as a result,
he's become relatively a lucky person.
Oh hell, I don't care about all this
at all.
But, can't really say
"Normal" defeated "Unlucky"...
The ceiling tiles just fell off!
Are you alright, Hii?
...because she still remains unlucky.
Hey! You okay?
Unlike she does, Satou's normal doesn't
affect other people.
So, is this a draw after all?
-Are you alright?
-Yeah... I'm... fine.
You don't look fine!
Let's go see the school nurse!
Hii, watch out!
CRASH!
Hii is trapped!
Kusuo! Why didn't you stop it?
I was going to, but someone cut in
before I did.
-Are you alright, Hii?
-Suzumiya!
Phew, she seems to be alright.
I hope he is alright.
I'm okay, but...
Satou tried to protect me and...
-Satou?
-Are you alright, Satou?
-For real? Why is he there?
-Yeah, I'm surprised, too.
But it wasn't actually impossible.
He is average about everything.
Actually, nothing was out of ordinary
as an average guy's action.
In short, Satou has feelings
for Hii Suzumiya.
DO YOU WANT TO SAVE A GIRL YOU LOVE?
This could be...
-Oh... I'm so unlucky...
-Satou!
So, Suzumiya was safe. I'm relieved.
Are you alright?
Wait... Could I be...
Hang in there, Satou!
I'm lying on her lap!
His luck meter is back to 50! His "Normal"
completely defeated her "Unlucky"!